[Musique]
quand on m'a appris que j'étais
championne du monde
franchement je pense que tout le monde a
entendu nazaire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'ai crié moiry film et il a balancé des
phones
ces thèmes est magique franchement
c'était magique le 7 avril caroline a
été sacrée championne du monde de
pizzaro l'italie audio avec cossette
alain patrick tu connais mon rêve c'est
d'être championne du monde allait comme
désigne les pizzaïolos d'être sur le
toit du monde ça a été des mois
d'entraînement j'étais là tous les
matins avec mon père je te vois les
enfants à l'école à 8h30 puis il était
là cette heure pour allumer le four pour
que quand moi j'arrivais tout soit prêt
si je m'étais donné ce challenge parce
qu'on leur a été champion international
ai a été premier français au championnat
du monde mais il n'a pas été champion de
france je m'étais dit bonjour je suis
championne du monde mon père aura plus
aucun doute sur moi et là je vais
prouver faire confiance
depuis 2010 est elle a succédé à son
père et à son look à la tête de la
pizzeria familiale initialement installé
dans le garage de ses grands parents à
saint priest prix de l'eau
et pizzas les faits démontrent
aller
[Musique]
c'est ma grand-mère bancaires
antérieures
87 elle avait la carte et petit à petit
va après prenant de l'âge elle a donné
la féra ses deux fils
c'est vraiment une sorte de famille
c'est vraiment une histoire d'amour
autour de la pizza à notre famille en
italie on est tous issus de la
restauration
tourne à des pizzerias des restaurants
on est tous là dedans moi j'ai grandi là
en fait mes grands parents de garder le
week end on joue à jouer dans la cour de
la pizzeria je vous mets pas ça pour
m'amuser il mon père quand j'ai voulu
reprendre ici il m'a dit tu préfères que
tu casses et de jambes que tu travailles
et il m'a dit m c'est pas un travail de
femme c'est trop dur tu arriveras pas et
je vais prouver que je conçois une femme
ou un homme franchement j'y arrive très
bien mes sacs de 25 kg de farine je me
les portes tous les jours
tout ce qui est physique j arrive très
bien autant qu'un homme gérer une
entreprise qui arrive très bientôt qu'un
homme manager mais salariés
plus vos 6 12 heures par jour j arrive
très bien aussi
[Musique]
maman de deux enfants caroline a
commencé à travailler à la pizzeria
quand elle était ado pour se faire de
l'argent de poche elle a continué
pendant ses études pury culture avant de
finalement en faire son métier c'est
beaucoup de boulot mais franchement je
n'en ferai rien d'autre enfin je vais je
fais pas autre chose que rien ou quoi
j'adore ça provoque et du plaisir du
partage la pizza sam on partage aussi
franchement j'adore mon métier métier de
pizzaïolo pizzaïola c'est on va dire que
sait on sur le métier de boulanger et le
métier de cuisinier
il faut qu' il ya le travail de la pâte
et elle travaille quand même un minimum
possible je veux dire on prend pas moi
je prends pas des ingrédients et hop se
balance sur la pizza c'est tout est
cuisiné chez nous ça c'est quoi vos
légumes en fait on les fait curieusement
celle que j'ai en ce moment la roméo et
juliette c'est une pizza bat comme un
challenge de fraises de bon grâce à ça
par exemple c'est ma la salade que ma
mère noël dimanche à manger et j'adore
donc je me suis dit pourquoi pas faire
ça sur une pizza
on sait que la pizza qui doit fait
gagner le championnat du monde et bien
c'est une pizza gastronomique en ski
composé de bisque d'oursins et omar
avait des gambas marine aux agrumes et
flamber au saké et saint jacques brûlée
au chalumeau des tuiles à l'antre-2
sèche du caviar sécher du corail
d'oursin c'est des pizzas demanderait
plus dans un restaurant gastronomique
moi je vends évidemment entre a fait 13
euros et les ingrédients cas dessus
c'est quand même relativement peu cher
de nouvelles zac de vendre ici en fait
[Musique]